Oh oh my god what was that that's the
most [ __ ] epic thing that's ever
happened yeah just wait till a nut shot
happens we gotta go investigate we found
it before ha oh it's upstairs got it
Gotti I got you got it oh and I can I
need to research this officer okay so
let's go investigate Abbott some more or
whatever
all right cool man I'm down you know
what I'm talking about right oh [ __ ]
yeah dude yeah I see an avid over there
man wait where'd you go I don't want to
get too far away from you I like you oh
you like me yeah I got over that hole
you mean nothing to me face oh thank you
you mean something to me now whatever
does that mean you're gonna shoot me in
the nuts
I mean maybe warm them up Wow I [ __ ]
suck are you down there
holy [ __ ] running around I got a double
kill or we go oh [ __ ] snacks I was just
looking at a MINIX they exploded either
I have superpowers or this is about to
get interesting oh wait I can shoot this
truck Oh God what is that on my position
run away from it incoming God's sake run
faster I think it's not chasing us it's
just our Tillery it's not it's not smart
it doesn't know I'm I've only got two
sniper shots left I suck at this you got
a grab ammo from people go hold Eon
their bodies you kind of got to slap
them on their ass until you find some
rifle ammo yeah I'm gonna go down here
where we kill all these dudes that and
try and find some rifle ammo I'll cover
you from the uppers I don't think that's
how you say it but thanks dude it's the
thought that counts man oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
he's blind I'm gonna search this corpse
for a second hey when I'm covering from
the uppers artillery they really don't
[ __ ] around with that [ __ ] yeah good
thing they give you
nice warning I always appreciated that
about 1 or 2 coming coming coming oh
okay alright the uppers it didn't pan
out up here oh [ __ ]
I'm low on health also I thought I was
fine on elf
right till the axillary blasted my ass
how long do you have it tell you're like
dead of dying
I like 10 seconds I don't know thank you
time though I'm good I just don't have a
lot of health so I'm gonna heal for a
second ok then I'll come get you don't
worry about it it's probably fine
well maybe not because I think there's
our tailor Ian's coming now we're good
we're good
looks like it's not good we're good
I don't know this is my spot ok so those
are the comforting explosions you okay
I'm okay I healed I'm good you good on
the on the uppers up there hell yeah the
uppers are secure oh god I'm not good on
the lowers I might die
I got no ammo I'm gonna charge in with
my machine gun and play this Call of
Duty style okay that didn't work out God
where the [ __ ] apparently I played this
like I play on duty yeah there's a tank
oh good yeah sorry I didn't warn you
backs and I have one bar of health it's
okay
I'm just chilling out of here it's fine
don't worry about me oh good I picked up
one bullet that will be enough is this a
stealth gamer oh you know who's to say
they give you all these cool oh [ __ ] we
get to start right here okay all right
I'm gonna get off the uppers the upper
Saints so up you know what I mean Lord
was not that much better I was just more
cautious than you go in there call
convoy wait we're missing an objective
what let's just go the [ __ ] inside it
won't coach tab man okay that's building
that's that's what convoy how you doing
we weren't supposed to kill these guys
that makes sense why it was so hard then
yeah oh they're up on the uppers they're
on the uppers are they do they see me
nothing else no they still think we're
up there I think no I think they see me
no let's go this way come over here all
right hang on I've got a pad this guy's
asked some more oh [ __ ] they definitely
see you they see me go this way yeah
they're shooting at you oh [ __ ]
oh that's all god there's a here this
your convoy oh okay good excellent
important fact
oh [ __ ] snake they grenaded me I'm
[ __ ] killing everybody
all right well we called the convoy
Elise so that's cool yeah Tibet it was
their convoy why don't we call what do
we call their convoy probably to like
trap them and kill them I don't know I'm
gonna do it again
I have like six bullets okay how in the
[ __ ] am i killing an entire convoy I've
got seven so you go up there I actually
only have two so this is really good all
around I'm gonna pick them off from a
distance oh there was a bunch of rifle
ammo up here by where you called the
thing what thank you I got it now
it's old lunch for me I know
ah so are we trying to be sneaky beaky
some more yeah okay you sneak ahead and
die and I'm gonna stay way away and
shoot him from afar how's that sounds
pretty much exactly like what's about to
happen okay I don't want to raise your
expectations too high or anything but I
feel like one I'm really not
understanding some fundamental concepts
of this game and two I suck okay all
right I accept both of those pieces of
information as fact
hey look it's guys I better shoot him
bang Oh nope hang on bang whoa his teeth
went away damn it these guys are really
hard to hit wait no weakness oh they
know where I am
damn Lawn Boy [ __ ] oh there's another
one I get a second try boom that's what
we're supposed to do oh [ __ ] ow I'm
bleeding out oh god I'm coming just let
me die even though you can't win if I'm
dead no no no I played a lot of Halo I
know how to do this and then these
Germans
they got something going on here not
strong faces man yeah like damn I mean
maybe I got a strong face I'm half
German like maybe you want me to shoot
you in the face and see yeah yeah come
on man shoot me in the face what are you
chicken come on bro no no shoot me in
the face I dare me to shoot you in the
face yeah don't stand up over there
that's not what you wanna be okay I'm
laying down is this better
oh god there's a guy in my ass I gotta
go over here Oh for [ __ ] sake get to
cover
oh Jesus where I shooting from there's a
[ __ ] guy over [ __ ] douchebag what
the [ __ ] am i bleeding oh there's
infantry oh you go die that's cool man I
guess wrong face man a strong face Oh
God oh [ __ ] are you alive still guys
everywhere over here those paratroopers
[ __ ] die shot him right in the dick
head all right cool I shot him in the
crotch but it said headshot so assuming
that means I shot the head of his dick I
appreciate that I'm gonna cut the [ __ ]
out of here hey I ranked up for saving
you again let's just [ __ ] get out of
here all right cool all right cool [ __ ]
the objectives [ __ ] anything
responsible man yeah oh we're really
close to that investigate a bit of I
guess though there's 160 meters away I
bet that's like [ __ ] want to kill any
more of these douchebags though it's
probably like the last one that we had
to do [ __ ] semi invincible German
douchebags last one dude are you kidding
me there's like 30 objectives on the map
right now no I mean this is like the
last one we were supposed to do he's not
gonna have he's not gonna have he's not
gonna be able to eat hard foods ever
again yeah cuz yeah because he shot his
teeth out yeah and he's dead there's
that you know that sorry about I think
it's looking at me maybe it's not this
rock oh good [ __ ] save me still out
god god damn it shows helmet up oh your
heart
alright miss bush I think I'm pretty
much invisible in this I'm invisible
[ __ ] okay alright then you eat
with it you just go stay there till the
end of the war yeah I'm just gonna hide
here until shits all done all right cool
uh but go and kill some Nazis will kill
this tag tag tank is coming up here is
this assassins creed no it's not
assassin's creed oh that tank tanks
getting close oh don't worry this here
don't worry no one's gonna find me don't
worry it is assassin's creed I was wrong
to the right there are guys coming well
they don't see me so I think I'm gonna
be fine I mean I guess we'll see if they
see ya know how cuz it might be the
perfect hiding spot yeah you got your
Bush I got my ledge we're all good
tank is it's fine it's fine take what
the [ __ ] are you doing dink it's fine it
doesn't see me how they see me oh where
where is that person that sees me oh man
over there by that tree got him oh he
was all oh they're our spotters that's
why they can see us
oh [ __ ] son dude's got a nice shot hey I
think we're starting to learn mm-hmm
sure I'm gonna go for the later you know
what I'm gonna stick with your optimism
I'm starting to learn mark yeah we
[ __ ] did it you know that yeah buddy
it's about Wiens a buckin did it
cooperation and teamwork and together
German people yeah that one
that's pretty much the main one actually
what are the odds if I run across here
to get into the circle of question mark
go for it I'll cover you all the tags
come yo your window is here alright
let's do it go for it it seemed like a
great thing to do
I've got you covered I have one square
of health so this will be all [ __ ] also
I just investigated a bit some oh these
guys really big thingy over here what
for us there's a pant there's a
Panzerfaust oh I'm getting that yeah I
like those words what does that mean it
means a tank blower-upper ah let's blow
up that tank how do we how do we draw it
over here I'm reloading my anti-tank gun
I'll draw it you know just the first
thing oh god oh god that's a guy up
there see you I sigh I didn't notice
that guy was too busy with distracting
the tank
[ __ ] take his [ __ ] shooting I
could have been a coincidence explosion
well what are the odds this is gonna
work there's a good idea like five shots
like this one
[Music]